sorry about the foreign secretary he has
described the abduction of nearly 300
girls in Nigeria as disgusting told Sky
News that Britain was offering the
government practical help to find them
it comes as another eight girls have
been kidnapped overnight by suspected
boko haram terrorists joined by the
founder of gender equality group made it
equal Deborah Owen thank you for joining
us on Sky News this afternoon is this
about sexual exploitation of these girls
or is it about them being educated I
think it's a Lynx hand in hand because
sexual violence is now being used as a
weapon of war fare in Nigeria and around
the world in conflict situations and one
of the major issues that concerns this
is that sexual violence you know is is a
massive issue but the fact that schools
are being burnt down and education is at
risk you know you've got children and
young people who haven't been to school
for three or four years because their
scores have been burnt down and so it
works handing a hand is that against
girls and boys or particularly girls I
think girls are particularly vulnerable
and being that we know that violence
against women is something that
systematically happens against women
around the world and it's a massive
issue that you know the globe and the
world needs to respond to in what way
what would be the best way to respond to
this how can these girls best be helped
I think I think it's about education
it's about educating the young men it's
about educating communities about what
violence is about sexual violence
understanding what people's rights are
what is the norm what is expected and
what is acceptable ultimately and I
think there has to be a push in schools
to teach them about you know there are
young women about their rights to teach
men what is the right way and what is
the wrong way not to approach and to you
know treat a woman and then to get
communities to be able to stand up when
they do see something happening to stand
against it what might happen to these
girls I mean the worst our worst fear is
that they'll never come home and for you
know the community for the families that
that's horrifying because you've never
got to say goodbye you never knew that
anything was going to happen overnight
sending your child to go and sit
examinations and the fate that they've
landed themselves in which is that they
may never come home they mean
be reunited with their families why is
why is the government it would appear
not doing more to help them right now so
many things are going on in Nigeria
we've got the World Economic Forum
they've got the national conference
going on and you know the community is
standing up and saying we want answers
we want a break in the silence because
and the president hasn't spoken out the
ministers haven't spoken out to say
exactly what's going on there's a lot of
confusion around and the situation how
many girls are missing what day did it
happen where are the girls and we and
the community want you know responses to
these questions it's an incredibly
difficult place for the outside world to
report from as well as a very dangerous
place isn't it Northeast Nigeria yeah
the north of Nigeria has almost been
isolated and the south is very rich the
South has a lot going for it whereas the
north hasn't got much and so you do find
young people going and getting a part of
you know dangerous activities as a way
of survival as a way to find community
as a way to find food as a way to find
support and safety for themselves and so
yeah the North has been completely
ostracized and a lot of work needs to be
done we've got partners on the ground
who are trying to do work who are
supporting the victims but it's a very
very dangerous place okay good to
torture thanks for coming out and after
don't appreciate it thank you